so in this talk we're gonna do pandas
versus koalas the ultimate showdown so
sadly we won't be talking about this
we're not gonna be talking about who is
cuter pandas or koalas but we are gonna
be talking about data science at scale
which is just as good right so just what
we're gonna talk about today I'm gonna
just do a quick introduction to doing
data science at scale which I'm very
sure that most of you are very familiar
with a few words on tandas again I'm
sure this room knows way more about
pandas than even I do but I just like to
get everyone in level set on the same
page then we're gonna talk a little bit
about what is Apache spark again this
room is probably very familiar with it
but again let's get us all on the same
page and then we'll transitioned into
what is koalas then I'm gonna do a demo
for you and then we're gonna do the
ultimate showdown and which is better
pandas or koalas
so a little bit about me so like it was
said I'm a Solutions Architect at data
bricks I have worked in a variety of
companies in the Bay Area since I got my
master's in 2012 in computer science and
I got that at Santa Clara University
which is in the Bay Area they also have
a BS in biology from the University of
Washington in Seattle and I'm one of the
very few people that you'll actually
meet that lives in California and was
born in California so and my folks were
born in California as well so I'm pretty
rare and so I worked like I said variety
of companies I worked in a small startup
that was an enterprise version of Apache
truffaut daeun which was a sequel on
Hadoop solution and before Hadoop died
you need a way to be able to query it
with sequel because that's what most
people you know have the most
familiarity with and so that's what a
package for podían was or is so I've
worked on five different distributed
systems in my time as a software
engineer and Solutions Architect I never
thought that that would be my like
passion would be distributed systems but
nevertheless here we are and it is also
from time to time I meet someone who
says you're my teacher and I'm so
confused by what they mean and that's
because I was an instructor for a
Udacity course on data engineering and
ended a group program that they had and
so every once in a while I meet someone
who took that nano degree program and
they were they recognized me okay so
again let's have a little bit
let's have a contest so if you want to
win this adorable stuffed koala now
there's only one there's only one
because that's all I can fit in my bag
to come here so create a great live
tweet from this talk you can tag me
that's my twitter handle you can use the
hashtag pie data in my feet koalas or
you to tag me that's fun really plenty
or pice bark and then stick around after
the talk I'm gonna go through this
Twitter tweets I'm gonna pick my
favorite one and then you get the Koala
okay so let's get to the nitty-gritty
here so why should a data scientist care
about scale right so we all know that
we're getting huge amounts of data from
a variety of sources click string data
customer data IOT data video and speech
data and this isn't going away this is
only growing more and more every day
every year but as a data scientist who
may be working on building models on
your laptop or a small server you say
everything is working just fine right I
am able to accomplish my you know my SLA
is my tasks whatever my business needs
I'm able to do that so you're probably
building models on a subset of your data
and you're saying ok that's working
that's working just fine so why should I
care about scaling up why do I care
about big data so there was actually a
Google paper in 2009
that basically said that when you have a
large data set so a big data set and you
use simple algorithm you actually get
better models so this was the white
paper the reasonable effectiveness of
data and they essentially prove that so
you can actually have your large data
set that you're getting from all this
variety of sources and build simple
models on top of those and you're
actually gonna get better results so
that's really why you should care about
scale ok so now we have that frame of
mind but let's kind of go backwards and
what is pandas right so pandas it was
authored by West McKinley in 2000 2008
and it sets standard Python tool for
data manipulation and analysis right
probably many of you are using it
everyday so it can deal with a lot of
different situations
including a basic statistical analysis
handling missing data time series
categorical variables strings right
that's what pandas are felt for but why
okay so that we know what it is but why
would you use it right so it's really
easy to start with pandas a lot of the
time it's the default choice for
teaching it's super easy to install I
mean you can get started with it just on
your laptop sorry about that so it's
super easy just get started on your
laptop it's easy to write tests right
you can just use all Python that's very
simple there's a huge community around
it again like all of you will probably
if I asked how many of you use pandas
everyone will raise their hand right
there's a ton of api's for data
manipulation it's tightly integrated
with different visualization tools
machine learning tools so that's kind of
why people are using pandas okay so
we've kind of talked about pandas we
talked about scale so let's talk about
spark right so Apache spark right an
open source platform and it's really the
de facto for unified analytics engine
for large-scale data processing so if
you're doing big data you're doing a
large-scale data processing you're
probably using Apache spark in water
it's a variety of forms right maybe pure
open source may be something like data
bricks maybe something like AWS EMR so
it's really good for streaming doing ETL
our data engineers out there and also
with machine learning so PI spark is the
API for Python for Apache spark and it's
it's very popular especially as the
Solutions Architect get data bricks I
mean a lot of people of data engineers
data scientists who use Apache spark and
I would say I don't want to give a
figure but a majority of its using
Python but there's also support for
Scala R and sequel ok so let's kind of
break it down here just a little bit
pandas vs. Apache spark so pandas is
really good first for like a single
machine workload right and just really
great for small amounts of data while
Apache spark is the standards a de facto
standard for distributed
quotes with big data so that's kind of
the two differences between those so
what's wrong with Pais bark okay so we
talked about how great Apache spark is
why can't you just especially all of us
who know Python and love Python why
can't you just use PI spark so what's
wrong with it well nothing at all
there's nothing wrong with PI spark PI
spark is very popular but the
integration isn't seamless you can't
take the code that sheet the Python code
that you wrote utilizing pandas you
can't have that and then run it on a
patchy spark it's not gonna work that
way they both have data frames and let's
dig into that a little bit so there's a
panda's data frame versus a spark data
frame so a panda's data frame and these
are just two very small examples I just
wanted to show here so for example a
panda's data frame the mutability it's
mutable or a spark data frame it's
immutable so if I want to make a change
in my spark data frame I actually have
to create a new data frame to reflect
that change where pandas you don't have
to do that now here's just an example of
some code of the value count so if I'm
trying to do a value count with pandas
you see it's just a the dot value counts
very simple if you're trying to do that
with Pi spark now while that's not
incredibly complicated it's much more
complicated than just using pandas and
again if you wanted to just be able to
oh I wrote my code here on my laptop I'm
happy with it I want to transfer it over
run in production on PI spark you're not
gonna be able to do it because it's not
the same code so here's a just another
example of that as well so here's I
think one of the greatest examples is
showing how to read a CSV so with pandas
let's see if this works here so pandas
you can see read CSV you just put on the
CSV file the pack to it it reads it in
with PI spark again not that complicated
work it's pretty powerful it works
really well but you see you have quite a
few options that you have to add in you
have to infer the schema I have to set
that to true you have to let it know if
there's a header etc and then just here
are some other examples of the
differences between pandas and PI spark
okay
so that gets us to what we're all here
today
to actually learn about which is what is
koalas so koalas was announced in April
2000 nineteen so this year it is a pure
open-source Python library that was
created at data bricks and then donated
out to open source so it aims at
providing the pandas API on top of
Apache spark so it's gonna unify the two
ecosystems with a familiar API so you
can have really a seamless transition
between small data and large data so
let's talk about what's good about
koalas so you can be immediately
productive with spark so you may already
have that code like we said you know
many of us learn how to do data science
utilizing pandas that's what's taught in
school so then I can come over to a
patchy spark which maybe I haven't
written before maybe because I haven't
had the ability to have a cluster
running because most of us with clusters
are expensive and most of us have our
laptops already all right so there's no
learning curve and so you can have a
single code base that works both with
pandas and Apache spark so you can just
have one set of tests you could develop
on that small data set on your laptop
like we talked about and then you can
utilize the power of petit spark for
production and running it on a large
data set again to get those good
insights that we talked about why you'd
want to run your algorithms at scale so
here's just an example of showing the
difference between pandas and koalas so
you can see other than the import
statement and I'll show you more of this
in the demo as well so import pandas as
PD in this case it'll be import data
bricks koalas as KS now I don't want
anyone to be kind of afraid here when
you see data bricks koalas like I said
it was developed a date of bricks um but
it's not it's not proprietary to data
bricks it's totally open-source and
you're gonna see here in the demo and
you can see actually where I am I took
the notebook and I put it online as a
Jupiter file super notebook and so it's
totally open-source you could totally
get this all installed even on your
laptop wherever you're running Apache
spark it's just a Python library that's
all but um just [ __ ] you can see that
the dot read CSV is exactly
see so here's just a word on the koalas
architecture so it's really just showing
you let's see do I have my yeah so
koalas like we said it's gonna be
unifying the two so if you can kind of
see here so you have spark right so
spark it in its architecture you have
sequel you have your data frames api's
you have the catalyst optimization
engine then you have your data sources
and then the spark core right and then
off to the side you have pandas and
there's no there's no lines between the
two right so koalas is really bridging
that gap so it's an abstraction layer on
top of spark so your so the other thing
just to make sure everyone's aware when
you are running those commands and
koalas you are running a distributed job
on apache spark okay so now it's time
for the demo okay so like I said before
my cluster shut off start it so in this
particular case for my demo you see me
I'm using actually the data bricks
workspace and this is where I have a
demo vironment setup now you'll see this
like I said you can also run this all on
your own with either like the data
bricks Community Edition
which actually is nice because it gives
you just you have a free single node
that you can just spin up and use and
start working with this it kind of
defeats the purpose a little bit of
using koalas which is needed for scale
but again if you just want to experiment
with it you can but in my case though I
have an 8 node cluster here Apache spark
cluster that I'm gonna utilize but
nothing here in the demo is utilizing
anything that's proprietary to data
bricks or anything like that it's just
this is where I have a cluster that's
what I'm using
okay so pandas versus koalas the
ultimate showdown so in this demo I'm
going to show you some of the basics
around koalas and then why we should use
koalas for big data with an example so
again like you saw before we want to
import koalas now again in this
particular cluster of what I have to do
like if you are setting it up yourself
I actually unlike cluster once it gets
I provision it I actually have to go and
install the library so I'm not going to
show you how to do that here but what I
need to do is actually install that
library on the the cluster which I've
already done in this case so I'm gonna
go ahead and import it I'm also gonna
import pandas and so I just want to show
you here in this first sale so we're
gonna kind of do some basic things to
these first couple cells and then we'll
do some things that are more advanced so
I'm just creating a koalas data frame by
passing a dictionary of objects that can
be converted to like a series like so
you just see that I have a B and C as my
column headers and then just a variety
of dictionary objects from there and
then I'm just displaying it so you can
just see how it's something very
familiar that you're used to with pandas
that you could see being done with
koalas and next I'm just showing you how
we can actually create a pandas
dataframe you're all very aware of this
I don't need to really go into that
we're just doing like a date range and
then creating like a random set of
numbers in a data frame so why I'm doing
that is because I can actually now take
that pandas dataframe that I just
created and easily convert it to a
koalas data frame so you see KS from
pandas and then that's my pandas
dataframe that we just created here and
then I'm gonna create this data frame
that I'm calling KDF and so if I do a
type on that KDF data frame you'll see
that it is a koalas data frame but if I
print it out you see it looks exactly
the same and it will behave the same way
as a panda's data frame so I can do the
same familiar operations that I'm used
to with pandas so I can take ahead and
get a few rows I can describe on that
qualitative frame and get a summary
statistics of my data so account mean
again all the things that you're
familiar with and this is something that
was important for me to show you here
getting data in and out via CSV so now
you can see like I showed you earlier in
the slides you could do the exact same
thing that you're used to with
Kandice very simple huh because it's not
it's it's all well and good to show how
you can create a data frame you know
from a few rows right a few lines one
two three but this is we're really gonna
be getting data coming in okay so now I
want to actually demo something for you
that a little bit more advanced here so
let's do some natural science so like I
said I do have an undergrad in biology
so we want to dig a little deeper into a
real data set so we're gonna be looking
at a data set containing the occurrence
of flora and fauna species in the
Netherlands that's where the data set
comes from on a five by five kilometer
scale so this is what's called
biodiversity actually did a very similar
lab to this when I was in my undergrad
so what you do is you take this it
wasn't five by five and because that's
actually quite large
ours was I think that's one foot by one
foot because it's just a lab for school
but what you do is you go out to the lab
or to the plot you have your notebook
and you document every single unique
species and the number of that unique
species within that plot and it helps
you to measure the biodiversity in that
particular plot so this data was grabbed
from observation org and its nature data
from the Netherlands so first thing
we're gonna do is we're gonna load the
data and then we're gonna do some
exploration so since my cluster is up
and running hooray
I can uncomment this code so I'm gonna
load this full dataset using pandas so
run this but I'm really just running
this for dramatic effect because this is
going to take probably around ten
minutes and it might actually if it does
exceed after ten minutes it also may not
and we may get in like out of memory
error so this is this is I want to get
my full data set here right all my CSV
files so it's gonna take a long time so
let's go ahead and cancel that so
instead if I'm gonna load a sample of my
data set using pandas so
I'm just gonna get one of those CSV
files and I already ran this so I won't
run it again won't attempt the demo gods
here so I already ran this now it's just
on one CSV file okay that was successful
great I think we can see the time here
so here's just taking a sample of the
data so we can just take a look at it so
you see it took around like five seconds
to load that one CSV file so for the so
right we've taken a subset of our data
now so it contains around you know two
to 69 thousand rows and 50 columns so if
I take the shape that's where I can get
those counts so instead what I want to
do with koalas is I can actually load
the full data set so as you can see I'm
good I just have to do some a few things
to ignore some warnings here and let it
know that we want to do this we want to
grip get this in as a distributed data
set so I'm going to read in my CSV
I'm gonna read in the large CSV file
then I'm gonna just again take a look at
it which I've done and we can see the
time here so this took around two
minutes to load it so instead of the ten
minutes it would have taken with pandas
and not been distributed because it just
would have been on one single node this
is now a distributed dataset across my
eight node cluster and it took about two
minutes to load and in this case we have
26 million rows and again 50 columns and
I did that again on this koala days
frame by taking the shape so I can get
that so I can also just as we're
familiar with pandas I can do a dot
columns and I can see all the column
names so um and if we kind of scroll
back up here I can kind of show you what
we see here so we see like an ID a data
set key occurrence key so just a lot of
keys the kingdom the file in the class
like Amelia and the order the family
genus species etc and then just more
information the scientific name etc
about what they saw in this 5x5 plot
okay
so then we can actually do a value
counts like we're looking at earlier in
the slides and we can see that we have
the most items that we have in this data
set is from the Emilia so we're seeing
animals and then after that we're seeing
plants fungi protozoa chrome ista and
bacteria and so that's just doing a
value count by by the column of Kingdom
so we can do a little bit of data
visualization using panda panda so in
this particular case I'm using again
that downsampled smaller data set so if
I make a bar chart on the kingdoms
column using the pandas dataframe okay
so it looks like what we saw right
mostly it was animals and then plants
and then small amount of fungi and then
it just kind of tapers off from there
okay but let's do some data
visualization using koalas so this is
our full data set right so here we're
seeing a slightly different bar chart
right we still see our animals as being
the most in that five by five plot then
the plants and the fungus but we see on
this on our x-axis we've now had added
bacteria now we can't see how you know
because it's just a rough bar chart
right we don't have the scale here we
can't see how many there are but we see
that they are available they are in this
five by five plot with our pandas we
don't see that at all so that's kind of
like that just take a note right when
you have a larger data set you're going
to get more complete answers about what
is there in your data set if you had
just used your pandas and you developed
all of your models around that you may
like think about like you know a
customer segment within your data set
for your companies right you may have
missed a completely unique customer that
you could have been modeling you know
for and you wouldn't even have known it
was there or your full data set you
could okay
so then I just did this one last thing
just for vine so
these folks find any koalas or pandas
within those 5x5 plots so you can see
here again it should be code that you're
very used to with doing search with
pandas so I'm just looking for the
location we're gonna look on the species
and then this is actually I'm knighting
then try to say it but this is a
scientific name I googled it for a koala
and this is the the scientific species
name for a panda bear and so if I run
that search and I do a display you'll
see that nothing returns unfortunately
but also it makes sense because this was
this is just for fun this is the data
set taken in the Netherlands so it's
unlikely in the Netherlands on a five by
five plot they're gonna find a koala or
panda mirror but we couldn't find these
adorable bears but that's okay okay so
that wraps up the demo there I hoped
that you could see how it's very similar
to using pandas and also the whole point
of why you would want to use koalas
versus pandas so let's come back alright
so the ultimate showdown who is the
winner and the winner is you right the
the community data scientists data
engineers now you have more tools to be
productive and successful so think of
koalas for scale and pandas for doing
learning and small data exploration so
neither one is better than the other
they're just good for the tasks that
you're going to do and that you'll need
to do so just a few words about koalas
so it's quickly gaining a lot of
traction in the community so the
developer community is actually doing
bi-weekly releases on it so there's been
five five greater than 500 merges and
patches submitted since its announcement
and that was just an April so there's a
really a strong community already
gathering around this open source
project so there's already 20
significant contributors and I think
last I checked maybe it was five that
were completely outside of data bricks
just people who have saw okay this is
amazing
open source project
want to dive in I want to help out and
so we're also seeing around 12,000 daily
downloads of koalas
so again just more on the status of
koalas so like I said bi-weekly releases
very active community with daily changes
so the most common functionality so
pandas right it's a very large API set
right there's a lot of different
functionality that you can do with
pandas not all of all of it yet can you
do with koalas right so the most common
functions have been implemented so
around 60% of the data frame and series
API and functionality api's have been
converted to koalas and 60% of the data
frame like group bys api's have been
ported over and only 15% of like the
index and multi index api's and things
like that so it's gonna take some time
for all the functionality of pandas to
be brought over to koalas but it's a
pretty good amount of functionality we
have now so how'd it get started so you
can just do a pip install koalas and
that's all you need to do but you do
need to make sure that right if you're
gonna run koalas you need to have PI
spark as well right because it's koalas
on top of spark you could also do a
Conda install koalas and there's more
instructions here on our github also
there's a documentation that you can go
ahead and read through and like I talked
about before the data Brooks Community
Edition again it is a free Community
Edition that anybody can sign up you get
a single node that you can develop on
and with and then koalas is already
installed there so it's just something
so that you can learn and play also I
strive you know let everybody know to
get involved so there's a lot of
different ways that you can get involved
in this project it's not just
contributed to the code or making a pole
request which is awesome but also um you
know test it out be a tester that's a
way to contribute contribute to
documentation file Jerez a file feature
request
answer questions that people have I mean
those are all ways that you can get
involved with the community and
contribute without necessarily having to
submit code but that's great too so this
talk the notebooks and slides you can
actually find on my github which is
github calm Amanda Moran PI data NYC or
you can just scan this QR code there so
I'll leave that up so thank you very
much I appreciate all of your time today
and that if we have any time for
questions I'm happy to take those Thank
You Amanda
please put your hand up if you have a
question we'll get you a microphone so
we can hit up reported Hey so this was
announced at the end of April you said
that's right how much time previous to
that was spent like internally
developing it or was that the start of
the project was April no they they
developed the project for actually I'm
not quite sure in the timeline think it
was around a year or so give or take and
then once I kind of got it you know kind
of a a good portion of it a good chunk
the day could actually donate it out
yeah good question
hey thank you this is really interesting
so I'm wondering a lot of times projects
like this that are an abstraction layer
around more like close to the metal tool
you lose quite a bit of efficiency um so
do you know I know it like is probably
gonna vary based on what you're doing
but do you have some sense on how using
this versus using PI spark directly
affects the efficiency yeah so I that's
a great question and a good thought to
have I have not heard of any because it
was built by the people that folks who
felt PI spark so they know those custom
connections to make sure that you're not
losing that from one to the other and so
actually I didn't show it here but I do
have some slides on how that cuales data
frame underneath at the end of the day
really is a PI spark data frame so they
just have a one-to-one mapping so to
speak under the under the hood okay
thanks thank you
great talk how question about a package
management for like a more traditional
kind of by spark clusters
does this require a cluster side
installation of the Korra library or
what can you tell us about the
dependencies that will be needed on top
of ice Park so there should be no other
dependency other than good question
other than just koalas koalas and then
so with koalas become pandas right and
numb high I believe but I don't think
that you need to have many other
dependencies other than just koalas on
top of iceberg um I believe you'll need
it on all the notes
Thanks interesting talk so I guess the
ultimate test of how easy this is to use
so if I have a lot of pandas code and at
the beginning I import pandas as PD can
I simply import koalas as PD and the
rest of the code works that's the idea
yeah like I said not everything has been
one-to-one mapped right like I said so
if you have something that's not that we
haven't implemented yet on koalas it's
possible that it would break there but
other than that it shouldn't so that's
one way to find out yeah
pretty much yeah and then file a file a
bug request right ramadhir thank you
related to the question before I was
looking through the library while you're
talking and I saw that there was some
sequel functionality that was
implemented so I was curious what kind
of like what kind of overhead is
incurred or what was the motivation for
reimplemented some sequel functionality
versus just using spark sequel so it's
really about the API it so that you
don't necessarily have to use the pandas
or pardon me the Python API so customers
they've requested and asked for being
able to use this
with other languages right and so that's
an example of that yeah so I don't know
if you are familiar with tasks but it's
very similar in the sense that it's
trying to get a data frame and put it in
a distributed cluster or something like
that they are also trying to replicate a
kind of the pandas API for clusters and
one of the brothers they have since you
get up big data that iframe put it into
a Questor you need to partition it and
distribute it so all the operations
related to certain so let's say a simple
certain of a column it's quite
complicated because then you needs to do
it multiple times and then like
recursively done did you guys already
address this somehow I see the it's
probably the 40% that is not implement
that is in that area can you provide a
bit more insight on that well I guess if
I understand your question correctly I
mean that those types of functionalities
are already taken care of through a
patch of spark right so just the gate is
to the about you spire exactly yeah so
like I said before the koalas data frame
is really just an abstraction layer on
top of the pie spark data frame so any
any operation that you're then
performing goes in directly into Apache
spark and is run there so that is made
for distributed computing so the idea
inside the organization is to make it
hundred percent compatible like every
single instruction or 90 high 90s I
think I think it's whatever you know we
get requested people run and stuff and
say oh okay hey I need this I think the
idea is it to be a community driven you
know user driven whatever it is that
they need but that's the that's the
ultimate idea but I think the team of
engineers who works on it is only around
eight or eight or nine so that's a lot
of functionality to pour it over but I
think that is the plan okay thank you
exam for one more question
my steps in
hi Kenny nice to meet you um so that
wasn't being ran in Jupiter right can
this be ran in Jupiter okay so actually
one eye so I Expo with data Brooks you
can actually export any of the data
verts notebooks adds a Jupiter notebook
so that's what I've done and export it
and that's what I put on github so it's
the Jupiter version of it and I have
done personally I have done that test
where I've imported a Jupiter because
you can also import a Jupiter notebook
into a data bricks notebook awesome and
so I've tested that you can go back and
forth it's not just a selling point you
really can I was gonna ask about that -
that was my next question about what
data Bruce was perfect Thanks
sure all right thank you everyone thank
you